APART.
CHADWICK, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING IN.
I APPRECIATE IT.
MEANWHILE, AUTHOR MARK STEYN
JOINS US.
MARK, HOW ARE YOU?
>> HIGH, I'M DOING GREAT, GOOD
TO SEE YOU.
>> IT'S BEEN WAY TOO LONG.
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THIS
BOYCOTT MEDIA?
>> WELL, I THINK, AS CHADWICK
WAS SAYING, THAT DOING THIS TO
MAKE AN EXAMPLE, TO SAY THAT --
THEY TAKE SERIOUSLY THE IDEA OF
THE DEPLORABLES.
THERE ARE 60 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP BUT NONE
OF THEM MATTER AND SO IF YOU ARE
PREPARED TO PUT IT YOU'RE NOT
COUCH TO HOLD A FUND-RAISER FOR
DONALD TRUMP IN THE HAMPTONS,
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
YOU CAN'T BE ONE OF THE
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE, YOU CAN GO TO
ANY OF THE FASHIONABLE PARTIES,
YOU CAN'T BE AT THE BROADWAY
FIRST NIGHT, YOU CANNOT --
YOU CAN BE ONE OF THOSE
60 MILLION DEPLORABLES SOMEWHERE
OUT OF SIGHT BUT IF YOU ARE A
BILLIONAIRE AND YOU ARE SOMEONE
WHO SHOULDN'T BE A MEMBER OF THE
LIBERAL ELITE AND YOU STEP OUT
OF THAT LITTLE BOX, THEY ARE
GOING TO DESTROY YOU TO TEACH
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE ALLEGIANT
YOU DON'T GO ANYWHERE NEAR
DONALD TRUMP HAD >> ARE WE STILL
PRETENDING AS IF WE DON'T GET
DONALD TRUMP?
HE'S BEEN IN THE PUBLIC EYE FOR
DECADES, HE'S BEEN PRESIDENT FOR
THREE YEARS, AND WE KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF WHO YOU ARE
THE COLOR OF YOUR SCANNER OR
YOUR AGENDA.
ARE YOU ATTACKING HIM?
ELIJAH CUMMINGS ATTACKED HIS
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY.
THE PRESIDENT ATTACKED
ELIJAH CUMMINGS NOT BECAUSE HE'S
BLACK, DOESN'T MEAN HE'S RACIST,
THE SQUAD CAME AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD HE WENT
BACK.
NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE WOMEN, NOT
BECAUSE THEY ARE MINORITIES,
BECAUSE THEY ATTACKED HIM.
WE KNOW THIS COMBINATION, DON'T
WE?
>> YEAH, AND REALISTICALLY,
DONALD TRUMP IS A NEW YORK
BUSINESSMAN AND IF YOU ARE THERE
ON FIFTH AVENUE DOING BUSINESS,
YOU ARE DOING BUSINESS WITH
PEOPLE OF EVERY SKIN COLOR,
EVERY CONCEIVABLE ORIENTATION,
EVERY CONCEIVABLE TYPE OF
NONBEARING AREA WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT.
BUT, AS TUCKER WAS SAYING, I
THINK JUST A COUPLE OF NIGHTS
AGO, THEY USE RACE AND IDENTITY
POLITICS, THE LEFT IS, AS A
COVER FOR CLASS AND ACTUALLY,
ELITES VERSUS DEPLORABLES IS
ACTUALLY HOW THEY SEE IT.
>> Brian: I KNOW YOU WISH
TUCKER WAS HERE.
HE IS FISHING WITH HIS SON.
>> NOW, YOU ARE DOING GREAT
BRIAN.
DON'T GET DEMORALIZED.
>> Brian: YOU GUYS.
THERE'S A REALLY STRANGE MOVIE
COMING OUT NEXT MONTH, IT'S
CALLED THE HUNS.
THE MOVIE HEROES SEVERAL
SO-CALLED DEPLORABLES FROM RED
STATES WHO HAVE TO FIGHT BACK AT
THE SEVERAL RISK RICH RODE
LIBERALS KIDNAPPED THEM AND TRY
TO USE THEM FOR SPORT.
ALL OF THE PLOTTED WHAT COULD
POSSIBLY BE WRONG WITH A
QUESTION MARK >> WELL, YOU KNOW,
I WILL SAY THIS.
I GET BORED BY X-MEN 37 IN WHICH
CARDBOARD MAN BAFFLES FRANCHISE
GO IN THE SKY AND RIPS A HOLE IN
THE SPACE TIME CONTINUUM.
SO, I ACTUALLY APPROVE OF MAKING
FILMS TELLING STORIES ABOUT THE
WAY WE LIVE NOW.
WE LIVE IN AN INCREASINGLY
FRACTIOUS, 50 FISHING NATION AND
IF YOU ARE A PLAYWRIGHT, IF YOU
ARE A NOVELIST, IF YOU ARE A
FILMMAKER, WHY WOULDN'T YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT?
THE INTERESTING THING FOR ME IS
HOW THEY TREAT THIS AND AGAIN,
IT'S THE SAME CONDESCENSION THAT
WE HAVE JUST SEEN, THAT
ESSENTIALLY, IT'S ELITES WHO
DECIDE THEY ARE GOING TO HUNCH
DEPLORABLES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SEEN THEIR TWEETS IDENTIFYING
THEMSELVES AS PRO-LIFE.
ANTIABORTION.
AND IT IS ACTUALLY THE LIBERAL
TWITTER STORM FANTASY TAKE INTO
THE NEXT LEVEL APPEARED ON
TWITTER, THEY JUST DESTROY YOUR
CAREER, GET YOU FIRED, CLOSED ON
YOUR RESTAURANT, BUT THIS
SO-CALLED SATIRE, I SUPPOSE
TAKES IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL AND
MAKES IT A HOT CIVIL WAR.
>> OKAY SO, YOU ARE HAPPY IT'S
NOT A MARVEL MOVIE OR A
"STAR WARS" 29 BUT I WILL SAY
THIS, THEY PULL THE PROMOS FOR
UP AND OUT THE MOVIE.
NEXT, ANOTHER HOLLYWOOD STORY
FOR YOU BECAUSE I KNOW YOU LOVE
THE ELITE.
ACTRESS ROSANNA ARQUETTE GETS A
LOT OF TROPHIES AND SHE IS MADE
OF BIZARRE APOLOGY FOR HER SKIN
COLOR AND A TWEET YESTERDAY.
LET'S GO TO IT.
SHE SAYS THIS.
I AM SORRY I WAS BORN WHITE
PRIVILEGE.
IT DISGUSTS ME AND I FEEL SO
MUCH SHAME.
MARK YOUR WITNESS.
>> YEAH.
AGAIN, THIS GETS BACK TO THAT
CLASS THING.
WE HAVE AN ISSUE HERE WITH
ROSANNA ARQUETTE WHO HAS LIVED
THE MOST PRIVILEGED LIFE AND ONE
OF THE MOST LUXURIOUS NICHE
SOCIETIES IN HOLLYWOOD THAT HAS
EVER EXISTED ON THE PLANET.
SHE DOESN'T MEAN THIS.
SHE DOES NOT MEAN THIS AT ALL.
AND, THIS IDEA OF TAKING VIRTUE
SIGNALING, WHERE CHRISTIAN JILL
ARANDA DID THIS AT ONE OF THE
DEBATES.
SHE WAS LIKE YES, I AM A WHITE
WOMAN OF PRIVILEGE TOO.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVE SOMEONE LIKE
CORY BOOKER WHO HAS BEEN A
HARVARD, OXFORD, AND YALE LAW
SCHOOL, THE THREE BEST
UNIVERSITIES ON THE PLANET,
PRETENDING HE IS LIKE SOME HOLD
ME FROM THE HOOD.
THIS IDENTITY POLITICS VIRTUE
SIGNALING IS NOW DEPARTING FROM
THE ANY CONCEIVABLE REALITY.
>> IT'S A SHAME WE HAVE GOTTEN
TO THIS.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE CAN SEE THE
ROAD.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING AT THE COLOR
OF PEOPLE'S SKIN, IT'S REALLY
THE CONTENTS OF THEIR CHARACTER
AND I'D RATHER NOT BE DRAGGED
INTO IT BUT IT KEEPS POPPING UP
AND IT'S ALL OVER THESE DEBATES
COMING UP AGAIN IN SEPTEMBER.
MARK, WE'VE HIT YOU WITH A LOT
AND YOU ARE JUST BACK FROM YOUR
SABBATICAL.
I DON'T KNOW QUITE WHERE YOU ARE
SO ARE YOU OKAY WITH ALL OF THIS
WORK?
>> YEAH.
I DON'T MIND MULTI-TOPICS.
I WAS JUST AT MY LUXURIOUS BEACH
HOUSE ON THE SOMALI RIVIERA.